hey guys how's it going Justine welcome
back to the summer snack today I'm gonna
making you one of my favorite salads and
this is something that I've really never
made before but I always order it when I
see it on the menu it's a watermelon
Greek salad or something like that
and this is also gonna be the first time
that I've ever cut a watermelon before
so a lot of firsts this week first step
you gotta get your watermelon I've got
this watermelon for a few days so I'm
hoping that it's okay and it didn't rot
you want to give it a good stab Matt oh
no okay yeah all right when don't waiver
bloomie we don't know well know that I
could he stabbed it this way it's like
yep just like that okay that's a because
I'm okay I'm okay
oh okay you're done now wait wait wait
wait no no no I also got it before this
was supposed to be my first time cutting
a water but if it was a stab nice it was
a good it a lot I don't know if that
watermelons good cuz I feel like it
should be a lot harder sake I don't know
if I cut it right
this is what I think wow this is
actually a lot easier than I thought
there's got to be a better way to cut
this but we'll work on that for the
second time around this knife is so
sharp you put them into your dish looks
good that looks great
so from some of the recipes that I did
see online you can either use lemon
juice or lime juice I'm more of a lemon
juice fan so I'm gonna use that in my
salad just pour a little bit of that in
there it also use real limes or lemons
but I'm I'm lazy I didn't even know that
I had a peeler and I can't believe that
I actually do have one so we'll just
peel this right up real nice
look at this precision have you seen
anything so precise looks to be about
right not enough maybe mix that up real
good real nice
now for some olives I would have got
some fresh olives but that would have
required me going to the store so I've
got some in oh no I can't open it
and Jenna just left yes I'm so strong so
usual I get the salad these are like
kind of crushed or like chopped up I
would say get fresh olives if you can
mmm so summery and so fresh now we want
to get some feta cheese put that in
there I'm not a big onion fan so if you
want to put onions in you can I'm not
going to because they upset my tummy a
little bit so option I even bought a
fresh mint tree for this project
add a little sea salt and mix this
around this doesn't really look very
good
you can also crush this mint up and put
some of that on there but I'm just gonna
throw it in there I want to get a little
bit of everything I got my cheese oh
yeah that's nice thank you guys so much
for watching this really super simple
summer snack salad have you guys have
been enjoying these videos they've been
so much fun to make and surprisingly I
don't think I've messed anything up thus
far ladies your comments below and let
me know what you think I'm going to be
making tomorrow and let me know also
what you would like me to make in the
future I'll see you guys later bye
come on little mint we got to keep you
alive
we gotta keep you alive for some mojitos